and I'll play I'll play one minute I'm
just curious let me be white
let me play a London let's see how it
deals with my London mmm that's fine
okay
96 is not so typical it's already kind
of moving slowly a little bit concerned
about you five but I'll deal with it if
it happens yeah this is what I want just
some solid like slow positional game
time advantage let's play rook could be
one mm-hmm I'll play b5 that's kind of
scary
this I just want to trade one's being
annoying with the Knights I got forts
may be dirty flag die got for it again
what's starfish works me twice but I
have Knights Knights are sometimes
tricky for humans to deal with but for
engine I don't know Dom we got to the I
got for it again and won't stop working
fee Oh
taking right okay I still have my nights
so Knight g4 dirty flag let's go ah to
walk my king up g4 die got me that oh it
Forks me so many times I thought it was
being solid no I liked my position likes
my position stock sack fish wouldn't
stop working